[MUSIC PLAYING]
PIOTR SZCZESNIAK: I'm super
excited to be here with you.
My name is Piotr.
I'm a software engineer working
at Google on Kubernetes project
and Google Container Engine
product from its early days.
I'd like to show you how you
can easily monitor, autoscale,
and troubleshoot your
applications surrounding a GKE.
A number of useful tools are a
part of the Kubernetes itself,
but to have a full-blown
monitoring solution,
we need more.
So I invited my colleague
Deepak to join us today.
Deepak, please
introduce yourself.
DEEPAK TIWARI: Absolutely,
Piotr, thank you.
So my name is Deepak.
I am a product manager in the
Google Cloud platform team.
Specifically, I work
on Google Stackdriver,
which is our DevOps tool.
And I'm really excited
to be here to talk to you
about what's available for
monitoring and logging,
and for identifying issues
in your application,
and troubleshooting GCP
native, open source,
as well as third party
commercial solutions.
We're excited to be here.
Thank you.
PIOTR SZCZESNIAK:
Thank you, Deepak.
So I'd like to tell
you a story of a team.
This could be your team.
The team worked really
hard to build a product.
And it's time for its launch.
They have chosen to
run the product on GKE,
which is a great choice.
And during the next
hour, you will see why.
Let's start with a
very quick recap.
So pod is the smallest unit
of deployment in Kubernetes.
A pod consist of one
or more containers that
will be scheduled atomically.
The containers in a pod can
share an IP address, local host
networking, and
inter-process communication.
Deployment is a
Kubernetes abstraction,
which helps you to
manage your application.
It offers straightforward
deployment, advanced updates,
including rolling update,
and self-healing mechanism.
Node is a machine
where containers run.
When using Kubernetes, you
shouldn't care about it.
It's Kubernetes, it manages
your containers rather than
machines.
This can be either a virtual
machine in a cloud environment,
or physical machine
when you run on-prem.
And kubectl is a common
light client tool
which allows you to perform
all operation on Kubernetes
cluster, like
managing your pods.
So let's get back to our team.
The code is written.
The initial version of
the project is ready.
It's high time to
introduce it to the world.
So let's go.
To render application, we
will use kubectl run command.
The only mandatory
parameters are
the deployment name, which
is bar-app in our case,
and container image to run.
We also specify optional
parameters here.
CPU requests to one core,
which will be guaranteed amount
of resources for the pod.
This will also help scheduler
to make optimal decision,
while choosing a node
for our pod to run.
This is required by
Horizontal Pod Autoscaler,
and I'll explain
the reason later.
Expose flock will end up with
the service being available
externally via
public IP address.
In GKE, this means that
the Google Cloud load
balancer is created underneath.
Port is the default HTTP port.
OK so the deployment
was successfully created
and exposed externally,
which means that our app will
be available in the internet.
How can we access
our application?
We need to know details
about the created service.
This can be done with
kubectl get service command.
We can see some information
about service bar-app.
The most interesting for
us is external IP address.
We can see it here.
The application is
publicly available.
We have some users.
And they are happy.
It's easy.
We have more and more users.
The team is happy.
The management is happy.
Everyone is happy.
But one day something
bad has happened.
Users started claiming that
our service doesn't work.
The team has to investigate the
problem as soon as possible.
OK, so let's do it.
The first obvious idea
which comes to our mind
is to check application logs.
We can do it with
kubectl logs command.
The command allows you
to get most recent logs
from containers
stderr and stdout.
In our case, we can see that
not every single HTTP request
succeeded.
The application was not
able to handle some of them.
So the hypothesis is that we
have some performance issues.
To confirm that, we will
check resource usage
of the application.
We can use kubectl top command,
which can display pod and node
level resources.
Indeed, the CPU usage is high.
As you may remember, we
requested 1,000 millicores
to be available for the pod.
So this means that
CPU is saturated.
In such situation, Kubernetes
will try to the pod.
The diagnosis is clear.
We just need more resources.
We can either request
more resources for the pod
or create yet another
instance of the application.
The second option
is better for us
since this will also
provide more reliability.
For example, when a node where
one instance of application
is running goes
down, we'll still
have another instance
running on healthy nodes.
In Kubernetes, we can
easily add new instances
of the application by using
kubectl scale command.
We need to specify the
deployment name and target
number of replicas.
The instance will be
automatically detected
by the load balancer.
And the traffic
will be sent there.
We may want to check the
status of our application.
You can see that we
have two instances
and both are available.
So, problem solved.
The team is happy.
They were able to
resolve the problem.
But Susan, the lead
engineer, is wondering
whether they need to
scale application manually
all the time.
So, of course not.
To decrease personal
overhead, Kubernetes
offer autoscaling features,
which basically are designed
to handle traffic fluctuations.
One of them is Horizonal
Pod Autoscaler,
which is an answer for the
problem we just resolved.
Let me explain how does it work.
So the idea behind,
it is fairly simple.
There is a Kubernetes controller
which observes application.
And when it notices more
users of the application,
it will add more instances in
order to handle traffic spike.
Of course, it also
supports scaling down,
where less users
mean just less pods.
Scaling down helps us to
save compute resources.
Horizontally Pod Autoscaler,
are also known HPA,
has other capabilities.
It works in the way
that it periodically
adjusts the number
of application
replicas up in demand.
It ensures that average CPU
utilization of the application
pods meets the target value.
HPA works within defined
minimum and maximum boundaries.
And it supports a number
of Kubernetes obstructions,
which have ability
to be resized,
including replica
set and deployment.
OK, how to use Horizontal
Pod Autoscaler.
We can set up scaling
our deployment
by using kubectl
autoscale command.
We specified the
deployment to be scaled,
we is in our case, bar-app
minimum and maximum
number of replicas, which
is between 1 and 10,
and the target CPU
utilization to 70%.
As you may remember, we said
CPU request to 1,000 millicores.
HPA, we try to keep average CPU
utilization of our deployment
around 70%.
This means that when
instances of our application
use more than 700 millicores
of CPU, by average,
the controller will rescale
the size of the deployment up
in the same way that
we did manually.
It will prevent
from the situation
when a pod will saturate
all available CPU.
And here is some rumors from
the Kubernetes community.
The community works
currently on introducing
two more autoscaling features.
The first feature is
ability to scale application
based on signals
from inside of it,
like a number of HTTP requests
or average requests latency.
This is important when research
consumption of deployment
doesn't translate one to one
to the necessity of scaling.
Another features that Kubernetes
community is working on
is Vertical Pod
Autoscaler, which
instead of tuning
number of replicas,
we'll be able to adjust
research the requirements
of the application.
This is important
when application
doesn't scale horizontally.
Once the feature are available
in [INAUDIBLE] of Kubernetes,
they will be, of course,
available in GKE.
OK so we solved the problem.
And we automatized the
process so we can feel safe.
Everyone is happy again.
But again, something
bad has happened.
Let's open the panic room.
Our application was
supposed to be autoscaled.
Let's check its status.
We can see, indeed, it was
scaled up to 10 instances,
but only six of
them are available.
We can learn more
about the application
by using kubectl
describe command.
The output of the
command is usually
a huge blob of various
kinds of information.
You can see only
a piece of them.
And what is most interesting
for us is the events section.
There we can see that our
pod failed to be scheduled.
The message says
insufficient CPU,
which means that
on any node there
is not enough free
resources to fulfill
the requirements of the pod.
We have two options.
We can either free
up some resources
by deleting either unneeded
or lower priority pods,
or we can just add more
resources to our cluster.
We live in a cloud
world, so of course there
is no need to call
our technician,
or, let's say,
order new servers.
We can just go to Google
Cloud and request more VMs.
But can we automate
this process?
At Google, we love automation.
So that's why we introduced
Cluster Autoscaler.
The idea behind it
is fairly simple.
Cluster Autoscaler
increases cluster size
by adding new nodes to
be more precise here.
The nodes are VMs
in Google Compute
Engine to the cluster when
an unscheduled pod appears.
In a similar way, when
a Cluster Autoscaler
can see unneeded nodes,
it will remove them.
As I mentioned, the
idea is simple, but not
the implementation.
For example, scaling down
is an NP-hard problem.
There is also a number of
other hard technical problems
to solve there.
If you are interested
in this area,
please join
Kubernetes community,
the work around Cluster
Autoscaler is open to everyone.
And the Cluster Autoscaler
is currently in beta,
but we've gotten a lot of
good feedback from users
and have made significant
performance improvements that
will be coming with the
1.6 release of Kubernetes.
Let me show you
how Scale Up works.
So a new, unscheduled
[INAUDIBLE] pod
appear in our cluster.
Cluster Autoscaler will
perform scheduling simulation
to check whether
adding a new node
will help with
scheduling this pod.
And in case the
answer is yes, it
will send a request
to Google Cloud
to create a new VM, which
will be adopted by Kubernetes
and become yet another
node in the cluster.
Then scheduler will retry to
place the pod to the new node.
Scale down is slightly
more complicated.
So let's imagine that
we have a cluster.
We have some pods running there.
The state of cluster
changes over time.
Some pods are
created or deleted,
either manually or automatically
by Horizontal Pod Autoscaler.
So we can see that a pod
from Node B was deleted.
And a pod from Node
A was deleted too.
Yet another pod from
Node A was deleted.
So we ended up in a
state where the cluster
is pretty low utilized.
Cluster Autoscaler observes
the cluster state all the time.
It will detect such situation
and perform a simulation
whether it's possible
to safely remove a node.
What I mean by safely remove
is all pods from the node
will find a spot
across other nodes.
In this case, the answer is yes.
Green pod from Node C can
be rescheduled to Node A.
So the node C is empty now.
So it can be safely removed.
So the benefits from using
Cluster Autoscaler are clear.
It allows to handle the
service popularity growth,
or just a temporary traffic
spike automatically.
It saves money when the
cluster is low utilized.
So up until now, we've
been troubleshooting
with command line.
But some of us, like Steve,
an engineer on Susan's team,
are wondering if
there is another way.
It's 2017.
We are immigrating
to Cloud world.
Can we migrate old-fashioned
command line tool
to a new, shiny UI?
No problem.
Kubernetes provides a great
dashboard, which allows you to,
for example, to do all
troubleshooting that we've
done so far.
And don't be afraid,
there is no plan
to sunset great,
old-fashioned kubectl.
So we can see
Kubernetes dashboard,
which offers a view of
events within the cluster.
You can see logs
there and metrics,
which is an area where
Kubernetes dashboard is better
than kubectl.
You can see some
visualization, but only
from a couple of last minutes.
So we've seen a lot of
useful tools so far,
such as real time monitoring,
real time logging,
support for basic
troubleshooting.
But to have a full
blown monitoring
solution, which is sufficient
for production use,
we need more.
Deepak can tell you
what your options are.
DEEPAK TIWARI: Thank you, Piotr.
So I totally agree with
Piotr on both counts.
First one, totally
love GKE, provides
you native, inbuilt
solution and tooling,
if you wanted to look at how
your application is performing,
where you're identifying an
issue when it's happening,
and then the ability to set
up auto scaling for nodes
and clusters.
And that's very, very useful.
But we also know
that when you are
running in production
environment, when you're
running large number
of nodes and clusters,
that you actually sometimes need
more powerful tools and more
capability for
monitoring, and logging,
and for running your operations.
So what are some of
these capabilities?
These capabilities are
things like historical,
monitoring, and logging.
So you might want to actually
not look at the things
as they're happening,
but you might
want to actually look at the
data, what happened maybe
this Monday morning.
And you might want
to see something
that happened on Friday, or
maybe something that happened,
there was a spike
a week ago and you
wanted to see how this week
looks compared to that.
So Historical Data, time series
data, as well as logging,
you want to look at that,
start to compare things.
Also you want to do
advanced troubleshooting.
So what you want to do is
you want to start looking at,
if you're looking at
a particular handler,
or a particular machine,
or particular application,
you want to be able to do
some sophisticated queries
so you can actually narrow
down a particular container,
or particular pods,
or particular nodes
that you were looking
at or application
and see what was
happening there.
And then of course,
visualizations,
so you know great
tools available in GKE,
but for more visualization
on charting, distribution
metrics, and things
like that, that
would be very, very useful.
And finally setting up alerting.
So when you are looking
at these metrics,
looking at your
log data, you might
want to create metric ad hoc
on that and then set up alerts
so that things, errors and
exceptions, are [? pilot ?]
and see whenever
those things happen,
you get paged or
alerted on that.
So we'll talk about what are
the solutions and options that
are available.
And of course, first we'll
talk about Google Stackdriver.
Sp what is Google Stackdriver?
So let's give a little bit
of introduction about this.
Here we have a very brief
summary of what Stackdriver is.
In summary, it's basically
our GCP native solution
for monitoring, and
logging, and diagnostics,
so you can keep running your
application without any worries
and identify issues
as they're happening.
But I wanted to draw your
attention to the keywords
that I have here in bold.
So the first one is that
it's an integrated solution.
So when we started to
envision Stackdriver,
we started to see that in
the marketplace, as well
as we talk to customers, they
are using a logging solution.
They're using a
monitoring solution.
They're using some type
solution and hooking things up,
but some alerting solutions.
Then sometimes they
have a separate error
reporting solution.
And then diagnostics and other
application level monitoring,
they are using something else.
But we realized that really
what you're trying to do
is it's a single workflow.
You had an issue,
something happened.
You need to figure
out what happened.
Go identify the
issue and resolve it.
So we envision this as
one single product which
has all of these
capabilities inside it,
one single go-to market,
one single package.
Second one is SaaS.
So as you also heard
in the keynote today,
take an example of "Pokemon GO."
They mentioned that
they saw traffic,
which was 50 times more
than not just their average,
but their best estimation.
So what happens is, of
course, as Piotr mentioned,
you can autoscale.
And you can get more
computing power.
And you can get more storage
power and all that good stuff.
But also you have to realize
that you're monitoring
and logging solutions
also need to scale.
So now you're sending perhaps
50 times more log data,
perhaps 50 times more monitoring
data than you envisioned.
And if you are running
your own clusters,
you have to now start to
see what you provisioned
and resize your clusters
and manage that.
With Google Stackdriver,
you have to do none of that.
It's completely managed
for SaaS solution.
And then the last one is,
it's the hybrid solution.
So of course, we all live
in a multi-cloud world.
And we also live
in a world where
predominantly people's companies
still have loads on-prem.
So there are use
cases where you would
want a single pane of glass.
So we are not built only for
GCP-- we have built in GCP,
but we are not only for GCP.
We are built for any cloud.
And right now we officially
support monitoring and logging
for AWS.
And in the future,
we'll expand that.
But right now we already provide
capabilities with public APIs
that you can actually bring in.
Your application might
be running anywhere
and you can bring in
some of those signals
from anywhere, from any
cloud, or even on-prem.
So that's really sort of
the vision of Stackdriver
and how we are
thinking about that.
So this, again,
talks very briefly
about things that
I mentioned, which
is the first point
around integrated.
So within the
Stackdriver package,
you'll see a
Monitoring solution,
Logging solution, monitoring
to bring in all the time
series metric data, and then
visualizing them, setting up
alerts, logging data to bring in
freeform, high volume log data.
And then debugging, if you're
hosting your code on GCP,
you can actually
hook that up so you
can actually see when
errors are happening,
exceptions are happening.
You can go to the line of
the code that is actually
triggering that and
you can debug it.
And then Trace is where you
want to get full stack trace.
You can go to Tracing
and then Error Reporting,
proactively identify the
exceptions and errors happening
in your application, and
gives you visibility into that
without you hooking anything up.
So again, great
out-of-the-box solution there.
So [? sample ?] all of
that in Stackdriver, be it
building, innovating,
[INAUDIBLE].
In terms of different
signals, like so
what is really happening?
So like I mentioned,
we are building truly
for a hybrid world.
So you might be actually
on any cloud servers.
And you can even envision
not a cloud environment,
but we support that.
Like I mentioned, AWS and
GCP officially supported.
And then you might be
running any operating system.
We support all the key
operating systems today.
And then you would be running,
so your VMs and servers
would be running that, and
then finally your application.
So all of these are
generating a large amount
of data, which come in form
of, as I was mentioning,
Log, Metrics, Error
Traces and Events.
And we can take all of that and
provide a single way for you
to analyze that Get
Notification on that
and visualize that data.
So let's talk about a little
bit of detail of GKE monitoring
and logging capabilities.
So for example here, in very
brief, you will see monitoring,
when we talk about,
again, time series data,
you are used to seeing these
kind of charts and dashboards
whichever solution
you use, and that's
what we're talking
about in monitoring.
And then logging, you
basically have all the log data
that's like a time
stamp, structured
with a text
[INAUDIBLE] coming in.
And you might want
to do more queries
on that data in
real time, and look
through what is really
happening, and slice and dice
that data.
And then perhaps,
actually, use the log data
to create more metrics that
feed onto the metric side.
So that's really at a high
level what we provide for GKE.
Now let's go into a
little more detail.
So at a high level, the
way we think about it,
or I think about
it, is divided here
into four high level steps.
One is Data ingestion.
You really care about how do I
get my data into Stackdriver,
whether I'm running
GKE or something else.
And then how do I
manage that data?
What kind of tools that are
available to me for management,
and what hierarchies
do you support
so I can define a
cluster, perhaps, and then
see data that way?
And then what's happening
with visualization?
What are the capabilities
available to me there?
How to actually see this?
And then finally, this
is really important
because we are building
GCP in a very open way.
Similarly, we're building
GKE in a very open way.
And then we are building Google
Stackdriver in a very open way.
So it's not just about
providing the product,
but also providing
you the data service.
If you did not want to
use Google Stackdriver,
but want to take all
of that data out,
you have that
capability as well.
So let's talk about that first
piece here, data ingestion.
So today, any log that you
have-- system log, audit log,
or application log--
would come in by default
into Stackdriver from GKE
through stderr and stdout.
Now that's not
the best solution.
So I'll talk to
you about Road Map
and how we are going to
enhance that solution.
But today, that part
is available for you
to bring data into
Stackdriver by default.
The other thing that
you're interested in
is in metric side.
And so Heapster and
cadvisor already
send system level
metrics, again,
by default, to Stackdriver.
So you would be able to
see that at the node level.
Then we have public
APIs available,
both for custom metrics
as well as full logs.
So you can write any metric
from your application,
use our client libraries,
built for the metrics, again,
and for logs, or send any
custom log that you might have.
So that's really the capability
that's available for GKE,
in terms of what you can
bring in to Stackdriver
and how you can bring that in.
Now, as I mentioned, we'll touch
upon little bit of the roadmap
and what's coming.
But what you will see there
is what we're missing today
is application level metric.
So it's not very easy today to
have a package solution that
brings all of that in.
So we'll talk about that.
But let's talk about sort
of management and hierarchy.
So the way Stackdriver
is set up is
that you have a concept
of Stackdriver accounts,
and you can keep multiple
projects that you
might be running on the
cloud within that Stackdriver
account.
And you can see the metrics
from those multiple projects
in a single view.
So you can create
a single chart,
for example, or a
single dashboard,
where you're seeing signals
from all of that in one place.
So you might have
multiple clusters
that you might be running,
some maybe one running front,
one running back end
in different projects,
but you can visualize
them together.
So that's really useful.
And again, within the projects,
you have concept of groups.
So within a project, you might
be running multiple clusters.
But if you want to define
a group based off of nodes,
you can do that.
And you can, for example,
again, some stuff
is running maybe on
staging versus broad.
And you can identify that
and create groups, and then
see the metrics
only at that level.
So you have that capability.
Charts and dashboard,
so you can, again,
visualize all this data, both
the log data that's coming in,
and then create
log based metrics,
visualize that, as well
as the system metrics
that we talked about is
coming in, you can visualize
or any custom metrics
that you're bringing in.
You can create your
custom dashboard.
And then you can set
up alerting on that.
And then data liberation,
touching upon that quickly,
you have the read APIs
both for monitoring
as well as for logging.
So you have metric data
as well as log data
that you can use read APIs
or take that data out.
But you also have for logs,
because we know that logging
data sometimes, when you're
taking it and transferring it,
you need a more robust
pipeline to be able to do that.
And we provide logs export to
BigQuery, GCS, and Pub/Sub,
again, at no charge.
This is free of charge for
all the GKE log data that's
coming in, so which also gives
you the power of other GCP
products, like BigQuery, so
you can take all your log data
there and you can do, perhaps,
more analysis on your log data
there.
We store the log data
by default for 30 days,
but you could perhaps even
keep it for longer in BigQuery,
or you can take it
for archival into GCS.
And then we also
send log data, again,
pretty much in real
time to Pub/Sub.
So you can actually
stream the data out
and you can take that to
a third party solution.
We have partnership with
many commercial solutions,
like Splunk.
And you can take the data,
for example, if you wanted to,
all your GKE logs or
any of the logs there.
So what's really coming
up on the roadmap?
So I think the two
things that I think
I wanted to say one
thing very emphatically
is that we are fully
committed to provide
the best in class solution for
GKE monitoring and logging.
What's missing that
is application level
monitoring from that.
And we are working
very hard on that.
We are working on as
meta data solution
to be able to capture
meta data agent,
all the information,
as well as provide you
with application level
monitoring, as well as logging
in a more agent-based fashion,
rather than taking it
from stderr or stdout,
or from just relying on
Heapster and cadvisor.
So there will be an
agent-based solution for both.
And then you've stalled out.
And you do not worry about
anything else, application
system, audit level information
is all available to you.
And then the second thing
that we're working on
is a curator dashboard for GKE.
So if you're running GKE
cluster or GKE nodes,
then you would be able
to see, in Stackdriver,
a fully curated dashboard.
So those are the two things we
are working on, in that order.
And you will see both of
those later part of this year.
So with that said, this morning
in keynote, Eric Schmidt
talked about sort of
freedom to innovate
but also freedom to choose.
So again, we're building
it in a way where
you are not restricted to that.
If you wanted to choose
a third party solution,
there are many good open source
solution, commercial solutions
available out there.
Here are a few
that we have worked
read that we have heard
that customers like.
And so one is Prometheus.
It's an open source
toolkit, as you're aware,
that gets you application
level metrics.
It scrapes all of that from GKE.
And it's an open source
solution and provides you
some light level of dashboarding
as well, like PromDash
and things like that,
so a very good solution.
Similarly, Sysdig, third-party
monitoring solution,
they are built
natively for container.
That's how they came out.
They were built for container
monitoring, so again,
a good solution, a
commercial solution.
And Datadog, Datadog is a more
generic, third-party monitoring
solution.
But they have really up their
game on the container world
as well, so again, a good
solution and a good option.
And then for log data, Splunk,
again, like I was mentioning,
we have a Pub/Sub
API-based integration
available already with Splunk.
So again, through one
click, if you already
have a Splunk running in
your internal cluster,
or Splunk cloud, you're running
that, one click contribution,
you can send all your log
data to a Pub/Sub topic
and then Splunk can
subscribe it to your account,
can subscribed to it.
We have a well-documented and
validated solution on that.
So those are the
things that we are
excited about offering
for GKE and recommending,
as well as what is
available within Stackdriver
for you to look at, and
what we're building.
We're really, really
excited about that.
And I'll give it back to Piotr.
PIOTR SZCZESNIAK: So basically
coming back to our team,
they are happy
because they can focus
on building great product,
rather than being involved
in all those depths of stuff.
Kubernetes and GKE offers them
built-in simple monitoring
and logging solution.
It offers tools for
troubleshooting.
It offers various kinds of
autoscaling, both cluster
and pod level, and more features
around autoscaling coming soon.
GKE offers out-of-the-box
advanced instrumentation with
Stackdriver.
And of course, you can use
any other monitoring solution.
It is possible to integrate
with other monitoring solution.
I would like to thank
you very much for coming,
for attending this session.
If you are interested more
in Google Container Engine,
I can recommend you the
following sessions, especially
before the first one where
there is customers invited
Philips Hue, who
will show how they
use autoscaling in their
production environment.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]